نتشرف بوجود دكتور خالد النعيمي رئيس
الاتحاد العربي للمكفوفين معنا هنا في
الاستوديو اهلا وسهلا دكتور اهلا بكم
جميعا من كاس العالم لانه اعتقد شهدت شيء
غير مسبوق فيما يخص
التعامل مع المكفوفين واتاحت انهم
يستمتعوا باكبر قدر ممكن
بمباريات البطوله
الحقيقه انا قبل كل شيء وهنئ قطر
ما فعلت وما كسبت وبما رست همم من قيم
اسلاميه ثقافيه حضاريه قبل هذا كله في كاس
العالم اما بالنسبه
الى ان حضرتك كنت من المشرفين على هذا
الموضوع احنا كنا في بلاد منتدى التمكين
واللي عملنا على تفتيش الملاعب وهمم
تشيك الملاعب قبل قبل الملاعب وهمم ومحطات
المترو كان معنا لجنه كبيره من موش الكلام
من كل الوزارات في الدوله واحنا كنا اصحاب
همم
طبعا
وكان لنا ملاحظات واخذ بها الحمد لله من
قبل
كانت بعض الابواب للحمامات همم اجلك الله
كانت صغيره على دخول الكرسي المتحرك
كان في بعض المعوقات
بالنسبه للعصا تبعت الكفيف ولكن الحمد لله
تغلبه عليها الجماعه واخذوا بها قبل
بدقيقه
مش ممكن الكفيف
يستطيع يمشي بالعصا وهذه
الشموع
المرتفعات موجوده فلابد ان تزال وزينت
بالنسبه للحمامات كنا لنا همم
على اساس الابواب صغيره عن الكراسي
المتحركه وموسعه همم كل هذا كان قبل كاس
العالم بسنتين او اكثر وايضا التعليق
الصوت الحقيقه هذا من انتاج قطر
وتعاون مع وتعاون مع قطر الفيفا ولكن انس
فوجئت بس سؤال في همم في اذاعه الفجر يقول
الفيفا هو اللي حط هذا المشروع قلت لهم لا
هذا المشروع قطري 100% اول مره اول مره
مونديال موسكو يعني مونديال موسكم
التقنيات رغم انهم متفوقين يعني عباره عن
سماعات للمكفوفين اللي حاضرين
انت كنت دكتور رئيس الاتحاد العربي
للمكفوفين منذ عام 2007
فشهدتغييرات في التعامل مع المكفوفين
حدثنا عن وضع المكفوف العربي الان هل يمكن
الحديث عنه يعني
يعبر كل الدول العربيه ولا في دول تمكنت
ان تفرض مستوى معين وهمم هناك امل بالنسبه
للاخرين همم
اتحدث من خلال منصب الاقليمي حتى حيز لبلد
عندهم بلد اخر همم همم المشاكل في الوطن
العربي تتشابه ولكن تقل حدتها احيانا
وتزيد حده احيانا طبقا للامور الاقتصاديه
والثقافيه
والاجتماعيه لكن هناك مشاكل مشتركه نعاني
منها في كل الدول العربيه على سبيل المثال
العمل
العمل عندنا نقول قطر قطر لا لا نعاني من
العمل لكن قطر لما تقاس على 22 دوله ااه
يعني هذا شيء فردي اا همم
تاسيس الاسر ايضا نحن نعاني من تاسيس
الاسر عندما يقول كيفيه اننا ساتزوج يعني
ممكن يرد من من من اكثر من 10 ل 15 بيت
لماذا تهمه انه كفيف
العمل بعض الدول توظف ولكن تهمش فاذا انا
استفيد عندما اوضح واتقاضى راتبا ولكن
اهمل همم همم طاقه هذا ليس صحيحا شكرا
دكتور طبعا
ابقى معنا بالنسبه للعمل انا من احسن
اساتذتي كان رجل كفيف الاستاذ سعد يعني
وفي كفاء عاليه بصراحه كفيف يعني ليلى انا
اريد ان افاجئها بسؤال ههه
يعني بعض الاصدقاء المكفوفين افكر فيهم
لما اقرا لانه همم ارجع اتذكر ان
المكفوفين طبعا يعتمدوا بشكل كامل على
القراءه
ربي سبحانه وتعالى قال وان تعدوا نعمه
الله لا تحصو نعمه واحده فقط
في قصه طويله كبيره كبيره لا نستطيع الا
ان نقول نحمد الله ونشكر فضله على نعمته
الحمد لله الحمد لله
المكفوف في العالم العربي عند تحديات ربما
تختلف عن عنها في العالم الغربي انه مثلا
تقريبا مندمج اكثر في المجتمع احنا ما زال
في عوائق مثلا سواء في العمل سواء
تفضلت في الزواج
ايش اكثر شيء تشعر انه يجب على المجتمع
العربي انه يتوقف ويحاسب نفسه عليه
والله ااا هناك رسالتين الرساله الاولى
للمؤسسات
والجهات الحكوميه
التي تقوم بتوظيف ذوي الاعاقه البصريه يجب
ان تكون منصفه في
الاعتراف بطاقات وقدرات ذوي الاعاقه
البصري
وذوي الاعاقه الحركيه على السواء
الرساله الاخرى يجب على المجتمعات العربيه
ان تقتنع بان الكفيف
مساوى لغيره من
اناس الاخرين يقوم بواجباته الزوجيه يقوم
بواجباته الاسريه يقوم كل الواجبات حاله
وحان وغيره الا انه ينقصه عنصر وهو البصر
البصر نحن كلنا نعرف ان البصر
يعني نعمه عظيمه ولكن ليس معناه ان فقط
بصري فقد حياتنا
اطلاقا عبد الله بن
مكتومه
على المدينه المنوره ايام تاسيس الدوله
الاسلاميه
الذي لا يبصر في العمل في همم لماذا لانه
الذي تعمل وفي يعني من العصر الحديث يعني
اسماء كثيره منها عميد الادب بالعربي
يعني انا سمعت على قصه اريد ان اعرف من
عنها منك اكثر بما انه امتلك علاقه بكاس
العالم وكنت من المشرفين فيما يتعلق
بالمكفوفين قيل لي انه المعلق المعروف
العماني خليل البلوشي كان اخوه المكفوف هو
اللي كان مصدر الهام وحتى يصبح معلق لانه
كان يوصف له بالصوت اللي بيصير في مباريات
كره القدم والله شوف انا اعرف اخوه شخصيا
خليل البلوشي انا ما اعرفه الحقيقه
انا اعرفك معلق لكن شخصيه ما اعرفوش اعرف
اخوه هو فعلا كفيف اسمه محمد في مسقط
والتقدير كذا مره
همم لماذا لا هو يعني ال- ال-
طفل الموضوع انه هو يعني كان بيعلق لاخوه
وبيوصف لاخوه واحب هذه الوظيفه فهمم
لكن الفيصل في الموضوع الحقيقه اللي انا
يعني اتمنى ان اراها
سواء وانا موجود او بعد رحيلي حتى همم انه
فعلا نرتقي بذوي الاعاقه البصريه بثقافه
ذوي الاعاقه البصريه
بحقوق ذوي الاعاقه البصريه هناك اتفاقيه
حقوق الاشخاص ذوي الاعاقه نعم من المتحده
هناك القوانين المنظمه لذلك هناك اللوائح
التنفي لكن طول ما انا همم لا ثقافه في
هذا الموضوع
ثقافه المجتمع اتجاهه وربما
لان ثقافه المجتمع هي التي تؤثر عليه في
العمل هي التي تؤثر عليه في الزواج وهي
التي تؤثر عليه في التعاطي مع البشر اعطيك
مثلا بسيط الان لو انت في الشارع وانا
ماسك عصا بيضاء هل هتعرفي عصا البيضاء ليش
انا متاكد لا الاجابه بس مش ذنبك انا
شخصيا
لان ما حطها في المناهج الدراسيه زي ما
بيعملوا في الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
وفي نقطه
في الغرب
في العالم العربي
يعتبر ولا كيف تنظر
اا ما نحن فيه الان في سنه 2022 قد يتغير
في 2040 قد يتغير في 2050 لانه الدنيا
تتطور المصالح تتبلور
الفكر يتغير يعني
اصبحنا احنا لو رجعتي للمجتمع العربي ككل
قبل 30 سنه يختلف عن المجتمع الان
كان ارحم كان
يعني ارحب
لاستيعاب همم ذوي الاعاقه همم لكن كان ما
عندهم ثقافه انه والله هذا لا حقوق وعليه
واجبات احنا الان اصبح انه في لا حقوق
عليه واجبات بس نؤمن بالواجبات
على العموم احنا جدا سعداء انك انت كنت
معنا اليوم لان فعلا يعني كان مهم جدا
يعني نحييكم مره اخرى في ما انجزته فيما
يخص المكفوفين في كاس العالم ومشاركتهم
والاستمتاع بالبطوله ونتمنى انه الرسائل
انك تجد اذان صاغيه في كل العالم العربي
يعني ننصف هذه الفئه همم لانه فعلا هي فئه
من الفئات المجتمع عامه تستحق
الدعم شكرا جزيلا دكتور خالد رئيس الاتحاد
العربي